welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the lord of the
leaks breaker of news and it feels so
long since I said that today we have
some big news on the Game of Thrones
prequel a Blood Moon
as well as the newly announced one
called House of the Dragon now in the
wake of the end of Game of Thrones
season 8 we did have confirmation that
HBO were moving forward with a G ot
prequel titled Blood Moon that was
starring Nyami watts this was reportedly
going to take place 5,000 years prior to
the main series and show the creation of
the wall as well as the formation of the
White Walkers as of today though we have
confirmation that after the pilot
episode failed to capture the interest
of the studio behind it the project has
been scrapped sources say that there
were multiple edits asked for for the
first episode but none of them really
set the world on fire
filming kicked off in Northern Ireland
earlier this year in June but it seems
that HBO weren't happy with the show and
have been dipped now this could be in
the wake of negative fan reaction in
regards to season 8 which is being
pretty panned across the board with most
calling it a poor ending of the saga we
also got news earlier in the week that
showrunners D&D had their Star Wars
trilogy cancelled which yeah great job
for rushing season 8 to do that looks
like a really smart decision and it
seems like behind the scenes everyone is
Reese strategizing to get the goodwill
surrounding the show back HBO did
however lessen the damage of
disappointment by announcing a new
prequel titled House of the Dragon which
will be set three hundred years before
the first episode of Game of Thrones
just do season 9 I'm salute idiots I'll
repair the damage absolute god it's
sorry I got a really bad chest should
probably edit that out anyway this is
going to launch on a new streaming
service along with a green lantern show
and all of the DC movies from the past
decade I don't know what it is with
these prequels but hey I guess they just
want to milk it as much as possible we
did initially hear that three prequels
of plans so this could be in line with
that
however this show sounds like it may be
a better direct
to take and the series which is being
co-created by george RR martin and Ryan
Condal is carrying the caption by a will
rain according to The Hollywood Reporter
the series is said to focus on the reign
of the Targaryen Kings in the lead-up to
the events of Game of Thrones and that
HBO will be aligning the vision of the
project more closely which is pretty
much PR talk for damn that last season
sucked Martyn has announced that there
will be dragons and fingers crossed this
doesn't get cancelled - now obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
announcement if you were excited for
blood moon and if this is just another
disappointment in the long line of Game
of Thrones disappointments do you think
the new show will reign fire or will it
be another case of the Borg Aryans if
you me these puns comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please give it a thumbs up and make
sure you check out my breakdown of the
other new HBO show Watchmen which would
be linked at the end we go over
everything that you need to know about
the first two episodes so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to come
chat to me after the video then make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which will be linked in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
latest videos on the channel so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]